i grew up on a golf course right okay
and does golf really stand for gentlemen
only ladies forbidden i thought it did
but apparently it doesn't but i still
think that there is we are denying it
ago in the world of female golf and we
could talk about it on a whole other
episode do women want to golf yeah badly
yes i played golf in high school i love
golf it's actually a fucking blast and i
say golf and stand up are very similar
okay because
i played team sports and i played solo
sports i played you know soccer and all
that bullshit growing up but then golf i
took it serious but golf is very similar
to stand-up because you only have
yourself to blame right but you will
like that but you will blame every
fucking other element it was too hot the
wind i got stuck in the bunker
and stand up you're like the audience
they were too
to me golf and and stand up are so
similar i just feel like yes i i i like
a i would rather a mental sport than a
physical sport um golf seems to me
unnecessarily hard like we have upgrades
in the area of sports entertainment i
would just be like i down like it's like
i just it's a whole bit about ballet
it's like we don't need to do that
anymore you know what i mean like
there's certain things they're like i
just feel like we could make the golf
holes like twice as big like because we
have to have them played golf whitney
this is actually highly offensive to all
of the athletes out there that have
spent their entire lives trying to play
the hardest game in the world now that
we have half as much time as humans
maybe we should have twice as big a hole
in golf
it's called evolution hey to everybody
on the lpga i'm so the lgbtqga
i'll join that one that sounds funny
i am into it it just seemed i don't want
to play a sport where i also have to be
a meteorologist oh yeah yeah like i have
to know the effect the wind
tennis
i don't do tennis i don't know the ace
love deuce
you know i don't get it i don't at 15
you got to win five sets of the six
matches it doesn't make sense it's
golfing seems to me like doing the same
thing over and over again expecting a
different result so the definition of
insanity you don't get to you enjoy it
for two like when i play volleyball
basketball you get to do something and
you need to enjoy it for a second the
second you hit the ball to tennis you
already got to be panicked right like
you don't have a minute to enjoy
anything good the golf is leisure i
think it's good on the cortisol your
adrenals shouldn't be up yeah yeah i
mean you can play it leisurely you can
play competitively i quit playing
competitively because my dad because i
was like the son my dad never had so i
was at my like championship game and um
i could hear i banned my dad from coming
to the matches and i could hear him
opening a diet coke can in the bushes
like i literally heard that
like
and i was like kyle mcmahon get out of
the fucking foot and we were like
playing in like jekyll island or
something and he was like god damn it i
mean my dad was a very large heavyset
southern man and i was like no dad no
you can't be here anymore so then i quit
playing competitive and my golf coach
pulled me aside in high school and i
very thankfully did this he pulled my
dad aside he goes i don't know how to
tell you this but she's got big boobs
now and it completely changes your swing
so i had to rework my swing and then it
just got i was like you know when i'm
out i'm out i was like
yeah hold her boobs down while she yeah
yeah
[Music]
one
[Music]
[Applause]
you